We said old threats exist,
what about vulnerabilities?
So vulnerabilities
could be of many kind.
For example, if you use a weak password,
that is a vulnerability.
Someone can guess that password and
then be able to use that
to launch an attack which in this case
would be taking control of your account.
If they are able to take
control of your account, well,
that is a compromise of your account.
If able to do it more broadly to
a system, that's a security breech.
So an attack is a successful
exploitation of vulnerability
by a threat source, resulting in this
system that has been compromised.
Unfortunately whatever it is,
are very hard to get rid of completely.
And they can be found in software
that runs on our computer systems,
networks, and lot of times
the biggest source of vulnerability
people say humans are the weak link.
We do things that actually introduced
vulnerability into the systems.
So the security mindset starts with
threats then we have to talk with
vulnerabilities and exploitation
of those within two attacks and
attacks result in compromise and
security breaches.
We're going to use
a really simple example.
You can call it a trivial example.
To illustrate this idea of
a vulnerability an attack.
So many of us ride our bikes.
And of course it's
an important asset to us.
It costs money to get one,
it gets you around, so obviously,
it's useful to you, so,
it's the valuable asset.
There are threats against it,
people steal bikes.
Let's think about,
if we just leave it anywhere, obviously,
there's a serious vulnerabilities in it.
The thief can walk and
take the bike away.
So what we normally do, is we lock it.
So as you see in this graphic,
this person who is security conscious
actually has locked the bike.
And they've gone off to class, or
to work, or whatever it is, and
you look at the system and you say well,
are there any vulnerabilities?
Vulnerabilities, some we
may actually know about,
others many not even know about it.
It's the threat actor who
actually discovers it.
And in cyber security
we call them zero day.
The thief actually is not going
to fight the security that you
have in place here, which is the lock.
And certainly what it is going to do is,
it is going to walk away with
the bike minus the wheel.
So vulnerability here was that this
asset that we have here the bike.
Of course the people
have to buy a new wheel.
But what he or
she is able to walk away with is
actually still fairly valuable,
isn't it?
It's most of the bike, add a wheel and
you have a functioning bike.
So the vulnerability we never
thought was that we had to secure
more then just the wheel, okay.
The lock that we put is actually
only protecting the wheel.
It's not protecting the entire bike.
That's the example of vulnerability.